All right. Here's how we decode the message.
We start off with the 15-bit message. We write it down.
Then we write the bits down in a column in order,
and we label each bit with its position number in binary
from 0001 all the way to 1111.
There's 15 bits. We're starting with 1. That's how we get the codes.
Then we make note of which bit positions have 1s in the broadcast message,
and then we pull out those numbers, and we add them together with wraparound.
So, in the right-most column, we have 00110, and that's three 1s,
so the sum is going to be a 1. It's an odd number of 1s.
In the second column from the right, it's 011010.
That's three 1s again, so that sum will be 1 in that position.
In the third column from the right, 111001.
That's four 1s, so we'll have a 0 in that position because it's even.
In the first position, again, three 1s gives us a 1.
So, that is the message that we're looking for--1011.